cela fait plus d'un an et demi que nous
n'avions pas vu ces images de salariés
non masqué dans une même pièce et
pourtant c'est bien réel le port du
masque n'est plus obligatoire en
entreprise depuis ce lundi 14 mars on
sait jamais vraiment habitué à avoir
quelque chose
sur le visage même depuis un an ce matin
on découvre certains visages donc ça
c'est ça peut être quelque chose assez
positive aussi voilà pour améliorer les
échanges dans ce laboratoire d'essai
située à montigny le bretonneux les 150
salariés sont soulagés de la fin de
cette mesure très contraignantes pour
leur travail c'est assez compliqué au
niveau de toutes les réunions qu'on peut
avoir en visio avec les clients et aussi
le côté un peu impersonnel des échanges
pour autant dans cette entreprise la
direction n'a pas souhaité que ces
salariés enlève complètement le masque
des mesures obligatoires un terme à la
société ont été prises aujourd'hui nous
avons choisi par mesure de sécurité de
maintenir le port du masque dans
certaines conditions
le port du masque est obligatoire quand
une distance de sécurité de moins d'un
mètre ne peut pas être respectées ou
encore lors de tout déplacement on verra
d'ici quelques semaines comment ça
évolue effectivement pour un prêt mettre
le masque totalement de côté certains
salariés comme dans cette réunion
peuvent continuer à garder l'accessoire
antico vide s'il le souhaite enfin du
masque aussi dans les écoles et les
commerces ainsi que du pass lac sinal